millions of Americans and cities like
New York Detroit and Philadelphia are
wearing face masks but many black people
fear they could now be labeled a threat
if they cover their face to protect
themselves
last month a miami doctor with a mask
was handcuffed in front of his home
while he was just unloading his van he
says that he was racially profiled our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
in New York with more on this story
Jericka good morning to you good morning
to you you know we interviewed several
black men for this story and all of them
said that they pretty much felt like
they were under attack when it comes to
from the police or even in their
community before this pandemic and now
worried that with wearing these face
coverings they could be seen as more of
a threat he was like either you show us
your ID or you take you take your face
mass out it's a pandemic DeAngelo
Jackson and his friend germ on best say
they were shocked when an officer
approached them in an Illinois Walmart
back in March
best says he recorded the moment a Wood
River police sergeant followed them out
of the store he recieves to tell us that
there's a city ordinance that we can't
wear masks and a stool the two young men
say they were wearing surgical masks as
they shopped for cleaning supplies we're
being asked to leave for being safe the
Wood River Police Department says it is
investigating the incident and the
officer incorrectly informed the men
there was a law against wearing masks we
left the store to keep out confusion
because the situation could have went
further infinity best in Jackson say
they uploaded the video to social media
in an effort to raise awareness about
black people who are afraid to wear face
coverings during the corona virus
pandemic this is a cry for help
forefront from our community right here
best in Jackson are not alone in their
concerns a florida doctor says he was
profiled in april when he was stopped by
police I don't know exactly what made
him get out of the car and put an input
handcuffs on me dr. Armand Henderson is
an internist at the University of Miami
Health System and tests the city's
homeless population for coronavirus
he says when he was approached he was
removing bulk trash from his van you can
watch it all play out on dr. Henderson's
home security camera we were in front of
my property and then he took me in front
of the car and proceeded to belittle me
and to yell and my face
the officer eventually let him go but
dr. Henderson filed a complaint Miami
police chief George Kalina released this
video response on Twitter saying the
department is investigating the city of
Miami Police Department does not condone
or accept profiling of any kind dr.
Henderson says he believes race played a
role in the officer's actions it is a
valid fear to think that you know that
if you have a mask on you you become
another police target this is already
becoming a problem
Ebru max Ken D is a professor at
American University and the author of
the book how to be an anti-racist he
says the fear of wearing a mask in
public even during a pandemic is shared
by many African Americans black people's
perceptions of fear is based on the
number of times we ourselves have been
racially profiled one California mother
already has that fear for her 18
year-old son Elijah Kipp he says even at
his young age he has had to deal with
that harsh reality I've heard a lot of
cars the police you know it's always in
the back of your mind that you're gonna
get profile there something's gonna go
bad you know his mother Jenny Kipp wrote
a post on social media asking her San
Francisco neighbors to be mindful of
their inherent biases when they see her
son or anyone who looks like him wearing
a mask we need to be talking about the
fact that this isn't about being a bad
white person it's not about shame it's
about the work that we have to do to
make sure that it's safe for black
people to live in this world I just
really hope that we could take this
opportunity to start having the
conversations and everything starts with
a conversation it's no secret that
wearing a face covering can protect you
from spreading this virus in fact the
CDC recommends that you wear those face
coverings when you cannot
this social distancing gale tariqa my
heart hurts I'm so glad you did this
story I had this conversation with my
son recently because I've heard this
antidote Li the story that you're
talking about he has a black face mask
and I said well I would appreciate it if
you wouldn't wear the black one wear one
of those brightly colored bandanas he
got very irritated with me because he
said what difference does it make the
color masks that I wear was supposed to
wear a mask sadly I know he's right but
sadly looking at your story I think
there's a bigger issue and a bigger
conversation that needs to be had here
I'm very glad you're doing it and thank
you and as that woman said it all starts
with that conversation mm-hmm we're all
very familiar with the conversation
thank you